it looks like margaret got to be there
have found her ken in the upcoming
warner brothers uh barbie film i'm so
excited for this oh this is my favorite
cast i'm saying and i disagree okay i'm
just gonna say that off the top okay
ryan gosling so this is the announcement
i've been waiting for according to
deadline the canadian actor is in final
negotiations to get all dolled up and
bring barbie's iconic boyfriend to life
the outlet reports ryan originally
passed on the part but as pre-production
dragged on due to the ongoing health
crisis his schedule opened up and he was
able to sign on oh boy okay we'll get to
my thoughts in just a little bit but
while we don't have any official
confirmation about ryan's casting we do
know the film is being directed by oscar
nominee greta gerwig which is absolutely
amazing and she actually wrote the
script so now i'm actually looking
forward to it with her partner noah plot
details are being kept under wraps and
production is set to begin in the new
year now jojo
i don't know if you play with barbie and
ken but do you think ryan gosling is the
right ken
here's the thing here's the name okay so
my fiance
isn't my fiance notebook me uh in early
stages of our relationship that's a good
girlfriend and as if i need
as if i need another excuse to give her
to fall in love with this guy you know
what i'm saying the dude takes he does
he's a he's a real-life ken doll as it
is he's walking around he's the more one
of the most beautiful humans i've ever
seen like get get out of here man
thank you
you are helping my uh excitement for
this because i completely agree with you
this is a guy who's proven that he can
be the leading man the romantic uh
interest obviously notebook he's the
serious actor drive first man i mean and
then he he's can be really funny too
we've seen him in other things and if
you remember a canadian snow called
breaker high he was right
like over-the-top kind of goofy guy so
with this film my hope is that it's
going to be the satirical look at barbie
and ken the perfect lives obviously
they're not going to be perfect um i'm
hoping it's funny i'm hoping it's dark
yeah you actually need a good actor who
can bring that forward not just someone
who looks like perfect ken can he pull
it off yes he can i think he has those
perfect looks but i also think he's a
good actor and chemistry between the two
is going to kill her
okay
bro i think you i think you're biased i
think i think she's a little biased
she's somebody has a clear obsession
with ryan
apparently i like to support my canadian
actors
okay okay i mean to everyone who's
watching who do you think should play
the can okay we want to know who you
think so okay so after you and i had
this discussion we had this uh debate
during our makeup time and i said ryan
gosling is not the right person to do
can
and then she you brought all that energy
telling me i am completely wrong so i
went back and i looked at photos of him
and his bow tie and he looks great but i
think chris evans
uh chris evans is everywhere no but he
would make a great ken okay listen he
would he's a superhero he has the looks
he's tall i mean i was thinking zac
afron for a second but i'm like
but ryan gosling i don't think he's the
right ken and if i could when the movie
comes out and is wrong i will say wrong
if he's not right but i think chris
evans would be the perfect ken damn
sangeeta that's a good what do you think
jojo would you want to see chris evans
hold on here
whose team are you on ryan gosling or
chris evans i'm gonna throw
i'm gonna throw one more at you okay
one more at you
what about chris hemsworth yes or uh his
brother um william liam hemsworth
liam what one of the hymns were bro like
good looking dudes i know but it's too
obvious
right it's too obvious you guys that was
this one might be too obvious
well i don't know is ken really that
muscular i don't know
i don't know okay okay okay did you play
with barbies growing up you know my
sister did i was one of the weird uh
kids who played with my little pony
instead but i did see ken dolls all the
time growing up you did and jojo did any
experience with the the barbie world
yeah i grew up with neighbors they were
all all girls so i of course i i was
exposed to the barbers i still tried to
put them in my race cars and drive them
around
um because that i used to make tracks
and stuff and we used to crash barbies
it was hilarious um that that that was
basically it
that's amazing those are some good
choices uh you should out there though
is anybody saying anybody else are they
guys i was so are they
with me or you let's see okay veleska
saying ryan gosling is not boring enough
to play ken oh this was the opposite hey
i agree with you but i think that's i
think this film's going to surprise a
lot of people i think it's going to be
like dark i think there's going to be
dark in a lot of comedy uh aj saying
since i did get cast as ken ryan's a
good second choice aj
uh and okay so we did do a poll who
should play ken and barbie 50
then chris evan oh 50. one more i just
need one more one more someone someone
bought the pole and make me win chris
hemsworth got 30
okay okay okay okay and then my choice
my man ryan gosling got 20.
what's up with this i thought i thought
y'all were all mine there she goes
that's a w that's a w right there that's
a w right there
if you're watching chris evans right
here uh bean is saying ken carson is
actually 24 years old so maybe ryan is
not too old lol oh that's fine some
people are saying isn't he too old for
that you brought that up i did i said
maybe he's not the right genre for a
barbie movie his but i i don't you know
i don't know channing tatum lost one
erica what do you guys think channing
tatum yeah he would be good too but if
barbie
[Applause]
i've been working out too
i've been working out too so you know
this is why you're on the show we're
here to promote you
okay